so the sheer scale of the crisis that
we've seen we're now looking at more
than 2.7 million refugees and we
estimate that over half of those so 1.35
million to our children um and so it's
meant that with the the need to scale up
very quickly has been critical now one
of the good things about poland having
opened its borders so quickly and such a
generous welcome is that people have
been able to get in they've been able to
figure out where they're going next but
one of the critical things that what
we're not seeing is being able to
identify key child protection risks so
tents like these mother and baby tents
are absolutely critical so that teams
can get in
children can have a safe space to play
mothers can just take their load off
their feet for a short while but also we
can have child protection specialists
and counsellors here identifying
vulnerable women and vulnerable children
because the volunteer response we see
around us is amazing but when you have
this many people coming and this many
people on the move in terms of refugees
even if a very small percentage of those
are at risk of trafficking abduction or
abuse you're still going to see
thousands and thousands of cases now i
understand you've been trying to get to
some of those besieged cities even to
deliver toys to the underground shelters
in places like kharkiv you know it takes
brave people to go back in there what
sort of scenes are you seeing yeah i
mean the unicef is trying to get
absolutely everywhere where there are
children in need and where are their
mothers and babies in need um you know
even toys can make such a huge
difference for children who are living
through incredibly difficult
circumstances even in the amidst chaos
when you find a safe space for children
to play to draw to be with their
children it can make a huge difference
in allowing them to start to process
their their
their trauma and start to you know
really figure out a way of building
beyond this and what about those
humanitarian corridors um we all watch
places like mariopol where they are so
petrified they're starving they're
melting snow for water you know what
what's your view of that first of all
and
what is your hope that might happen for
the people that are there certainly i
mean the images that we've all seen are
horrific and just yesterday our
executive director along with the
executive director of who and unfpa
issued a statement calling urgently for
the end of attacks on health care we've
seen pregnant women killed we've seen
babies in the rubble you know these are
unconscionable acts so we have to see an
end to that we're ready to get our
people in and to provide the care that's
needed but we can't do that if bombs are
falling and bullets are flying we need a
humanitarian pause we need a ceasefire
and ultimately the children of ukraine
need peace
i mean it's terrible isn't it and you
see that the faces of people who arrive
here there's sort of a blankness of the
trauma in their faces they're absolutely
exhausted is there anything more that
can be done do you think to you know
this is now quite well organized people
say it's definitely better than it was
at the start but is there anything more
that you know people watching at home
can do yeah certainly i mean when we
have a crisis of this scale it's clear
that we need international solidarity we
need not only funding from governments
and governments to step up in terms of
the refugee response but also
individuals can help if you go onto
unicef.org.uk you can donate and this
this kind of funds allow us to do things
like get midwife kits into these
hospitals that we're seeing so doctors
and nurses working in the most difficult
conditions can do their job they have
the supplies the oxygen the midwife kits
that they need to deliver children into
this world well joey